I mean we have with us Luis Esposito the
executive producer of this film and also
so many Marvel films we have seen every
single one you know you're no stranger
to these carpets here and you know let's
talk about you know the Guardians you
know I can't imagine when you first had
pitch and we're going to work on this
did you have any idea that there would
be this worldwide I mean galaxy-wide
phenomenon that they have become
absolutely not when you when you start
thinking about the Guardians you have a
talking tree that only says I am Groot
and then and a raccoon so how how is
this going to be successful but they're
a misfit group of people that come
together they're a great family like all
families they they fight they love each
other and at the end they defend each
other so it's great well like we said
you've been an executive producer for
all the MCU films thus far but
especially the three Galaxy of our
Guardians of the Galaxy film I mean
what's it like to see the end of this
era well maybe it's not the end
[Music]
but no this specific team right yeah
well you know uh it's it's quite this
movie is so heartfelt and so much fun at
the same time that uh I'm absolutely
this is the best oh three wow and I know
you don't say that lightly I know yeah
well you know we're also introducing
some new characters what was it like to
bring in like the high evolutionary and
Adam Warlock onto the scene oh they're
bad
we talked to them and they were like you
better be ready I I don't wanna they're
they're really good the high
evolutionary is a great villain and and
Adam Warlock is amazing amazing well
listen we're surrounded by cosplayers
who can defend you if they come after
you for those statements and you'll be
safe I'm sure thank you well thank you
thank you so much thank you so much